rock and roll and football
super bowl weekend is officially upon us
and that means it is time for our annual
super bowl
city showdown as the buccaneers and
chiefs get ready to battle it out on the
field
we are looking at how their hometowns
stack up against one another
so we sent cbs this morning saturday
co-host michelle miller
to beautiful kansas city and jamie ukis
to tampa
which is already enjoying some home
field
since they are hosting this year's big
game
let's just start where it matters most
at quarterback this
is the grady goat foundation turn that g
into a b
and you've got brady goat as in tom
brady the greatest of all time
[Music]
brady is a 14-time pro bowl quarterback
a three-time league mvp
and of course the winner of six count em
six super bowl rings
sure but he did all that as a new
england patriot
and don't forget a baby goat is a kid
in kansas city's kid quarterback patrick
mahomes is just getting started
mahomes already has a ring from last
year's super bowl
and he's ready for more isn't that right
kids
[Music]
you know the tampa bay area is made up
of three cities tampa st
petersburg and clearwater this beautiful
cable state bridge
the sunshine skyway stretches across the
lower tampa bay
and spans three separate counties one
bridge
three counties how about this one street
two states both kansas city
over here you're in kansas city kansas
and over here you're in kansas city
missouri
or missouri depending on what part of
the state you're from
one city two states i got that beat
right now i'm standing in tampa in the
good old usa
but once i walk through this gate i'm in
cuba
this little space called jose marti park
was given to the cuban government in
1956
and the island nation still owns it
today and speaking of cuba
the cuban sandwich not invented in
havana
but right here in tampa fla
you want to talk about food really
kansas city
is all about the barbecue and kansas
speedway
is home to the american royal world
series of barbecue the world's
largest barbecue contest and this
i can smell that smoky goodness smoke in
the 1880s cigar makers moved into tampa
and started hand rolling the product
right here
hundreds of millions of cigars were
produced earning tampa the nickname
cigar city flip the calendar back and
the kansas city area was both free
and slave territory before the civil war
the underground railroad led people
across the missouri
to freedom in kansas kansas city is
where you'll find the world's
largest batman birdie also known as
the shuttlecock yeah michelle we heard
all about the biggest birdie last year
but when it comes to badminton
no one has tampa top the longest
badminton doubles marathon
ever took place between two tampa teams
and lasted a whopping 32 hours in 25
minutes
[Music]
another record tampa holds longest
continuous sidewalk
this is bay shore boulevard it runs four
and a half miles
that's a pretty long sidewalk for sure
but the sidewalks here in kansas city
are home to the largest pub crawls
ever in 2013 85 people took part and
more than 4 500 gallons of beer were
ordered
if you do the math that amounts to about
a gallon of beer per person
hey what are you doing
this one's for you mahomes dry january's
over
st petersburg is home to the world's
largest shuffleboard club
kansas city has a castle saint pete once
recorded 768 straight sunny
days invented in kansas city the bumper
sticker
the crock-pot the first scheduled
commercial airline flight took off from
this saint petersburg waterfront in
1914.
23 minutes later it landed here at the
entrance of the hillsborough river
in tampa not going to lie that's
impressive
but here's a first for kansas city best
shopping mall
in 1922 the country club plaza opened
and changed the way americans buy their
stuff
hey jamie this one's on cbs
make sure you pick me up a little
something but michelle while you shop
we really should be talking about sports
and tampa bay is on a roll
the tampa bay lightning won the stanley
cup the tampa bay rays made it to the
world series
and the tampa bay buccaneers are in the
super bowl
a a forget about those other sports
because we're talking about football so
good luck buccaneers brady or not
because the defending super bowl
champions
are from right here in kansas city
i think we need a slow clap here
well done michelle and jamie join us now
uh good morning to both of you
going into this did you have any
preconceptions jamie swag
yeah where is her swag yeah i know she's
got sunshine all around her that's what
she's working on i got this
what else do you need michelle i win big
time with this view
you went you went glamour girl no i i
gotta
do a shout out to my girl mari salon
she's a huge kansas city fan
because i am debt you got to show up and
we should point out that the snow is in
new jersey
not in kansas city so i was in new
jersey
what was the most surprising thing you
guys learned about your respective
cities
michelle you're up first
you you put me on the spot here the most
surprising
probably uh the shopping center yeah
the shopping center kind of surprised me
yeah yeah
i knew about slave free state i knew all
about that
of course i knew about the barbecue uh
but yeah
the the shuttlecock in the in the
shopping center didn't know
jamie what about you so i didn't realize
that cuban sandwich was actually
invented
here in tampa which they're delicious by
the way i've had one every single day
for lunch i'm hoping to be sick of them
by the time i get home because i don't
know how to make them myself
um but yeah the other surprising thing
is that when you do goat yoga
they leave hoof hoof hoof marks on your
back
uh they just healed today yeah i want to
know how long it took for you to get
that goat to stand on your back
there oh it takes seconds for the goat
to actually stand on your back but when
you've got 50 goats that are all trying
to get on your back at the same time
it probably took about a hundred takes
for me to get it just right so
there's a little screaming involved at
some points too jamie i'm just glad that
you explained it was goat yoga because
if people didn't know they think you
might have
some issues and we might need to get you
some help down there on all fours with
the goat so i'm
glad you explained that and then you had
the scene where you go from tampa to
cuba
tony and i both looked at anthony and
said is that true can you go to cuba i
thought that's something i learned
and michelle i used to work in kansas
city i love that city crowne plaza the
shopping is great
great people there those are really
great stories both of them yeah
all right and of course we leave it to
our viewers to make the ultimate
decision which
city is better tampa kansas city
thank you both super bowl sunday this
sunday
on cbs game starts at 6 p.m and before
kickoff in the 4 p.m eastern hour
see norah o'donnell's wide-ranging
interview with president biden
his first on network tv since taking off